i'm a lifelong traveler
even as a little kid i was actually
working out
that it would be cheaper to go to
boarding school in england
than just to the best school down the
road from my parents house
in california and so from the time i was
nine years old
i was flying alone several times a year
over the north pole just to go to school
and of course the more i flew the more i
came to love to fly
so the very week after i graduated from
high school
i got a job mopping tables so that i
could spend
every season of my 18th year on
a different continent and then
almost inevitably i became a travel
writer
so my job and my joy could become
one and i really began to feel
that if you were lucky enough to walk
around the
candlelit temples of tibet or to wander
along the seafront
in havana with music passing all around
you
you could bring those sounds and the
high cobalt skies and
the flash of the blue ocean back to your
friends at home
and really bring some magic and clarity
to your own life
except as you all know one of the first
things you learn
when you travel is that nowhere is
magical
unless you can bring the right eyes to
it
you take an angry man to the himalayas
he just starts complaining about the
food
and i found that the best way that i
could develop
more attentive and more appreciative
eyes was
oddly by going nowhere just by sitting
still
and of course sitting still is how many
of us get what we
most crave and need in our accelerated
lives
a break but it was also the only way
that i could find
to sift through the slideshow of my
experience and make sense
of the future and the past and so
to my great surprise i found that going
nowhere
was at least as exciting as going to
tibet or to cuba
and by going nowhere i mean nothing more
intimidating than taking a few minutes
out of every day or
a few days out of every season or even
as some people do
a few years out of a life in order to
sit still
long enough to find out what moves you
most
to recall where your truest happiness
lies
and to remember that sometimes making a
living and making a life
point in opposite directions
and of course this is what wise beings
through the centuries from every
tradition
have been telling us it's an old idea
more than
two thousand years ago the stoics were
reminding us it's not our experience
that makes our lives
it's what we do with it imagine a
hurricane suddenly sweeps through your
town and reduces
every last thing to rubble
one man is traumatized for life
but another maybe even his brother
almost feels liberated and decides this
is a great chance
to start his life anew it's exactly the
same event
but radically different responses
there's nothing either good
or bad as shakespeare told us in hamlet
but
thinking makes it so
and this has certainly been my
experience as a traveler
at 24 years ago i took the most
mind-bending trip
across north korea but the trip lasted
a few days what i've done with it
sitting still
going back to it in my head trying to
understand it finding a place for it in
my thinking
that's lasted 24 years already and will
probably last
a lifetime the trip in other words
gave me some amazing sights but it's
only sitting still
that allows me to turn those into
lasting insights
and i sometimes think that so much of
our life takes place inside our heads
in memory or imagination or
interpretation or speculation
that if i really want to change my life
i might best begin
by changing my mind again
none of this is new that's why
shakespeare and the stoics were telling
us this
centuries ago but shakespeare
never had to face 200 emails in a day
the stoics as far as i know were not on
facebook
we all know that in our on-demand lives
one of the things that's most on demand
is ourselves wherever we are any time of
night or day
our bosses junk mailers our parents can
get to us
sociologists have actually found that in
recent years
americans are working fewer hours than
50 years ago
but we feel as if we're working more
we have more and more time saving
devices but sometimes it seems
less and less time we can more and more
easily make contact with people on the
furthest corners of the planet
but sometimes in that process we lose
contact
with ourselves and one of my
biggest surprises as a traveler has been
to find that
often it's exactly the people who have
most enabled us to get anywhere
who are intent on going nowhere in other
words precisely those beings
who have created the technologies that
override
so many of the limits of old are the
ones
wisest about the need for limits even
when it comes
to technology i
once went to the google headquarters and
i saw all the things many of you have
heard about the
indoor treehouses the trampolines
workers
at that time enjoying 20 of their paid
time
free so that they could just let their
imaginations go
wandering but what impressed me even
more
was that as i was waiting for my digital
id
one googler was telling me about the
program that he was about to start
to teach the many many googlers who
practice yoga
to become trainers in it and the other
googler was telling me about the book
that he was about to
write on the inner search engine
and the ways in which science has
empirically shown
that sitting still or meditation can
lead
not just to better health or to clear a
thinking but even
to emotional intelligence i have another
friend in in silicon valley who's really
one of the most eloquent spokesman for
the latest technologies and in fact
was one of the founders of wired
magazine kevin kelly
and kevin wrote his last book on fresh
technologies
without a smartphone or a laptop or a tv
in his home
and like many in silicon valley
he tries really hard to observe what
they call
an internet sabbath whereby for
24 or 48 hours every week they go
completely
offline in order to gather the sense of
direction and proportion they'll need
when they go online again the one thing
perhaps that technology hasn't always
given us
is a sense of how to make the wisest use
of technology
and when you speak of the sabbath look
at the ten commandments
there's only one word there for which
the adjective holy is used
that's the sabbath i pick up the jewish
holy book of the torah
its longest chapter it's on the sabbath
and we all know that it's really one of
our greatest luxuries
the empty space in many a piece of music
it's the pores or the rest that gives
the piece its beauty
and its shape and i know i as a writer
will often try to include
a lot of empty space on the page so that
the reader can complete
my thoughts and sentences and so that
her imagination
has room to breathe
now in the physical domain of course
many people if they have the resources
will try to get a place in the country a
second home
i've never begun to have those resources
but i sometimes remember that anytime i
want
i can get a second home in time
if not in space just by taking a day off
and it's never easy because of course
whenever i do i spend much of it
worried about all the extra stuff that's
going to crash down on me
the following day i sometimes think i'd
rather give up meat or sex or wine than
the chance to check on my emails
and every season i do try to take three
days off on retreat
but a part of me still feels guilty to
be leaving my poor wife behind and
to be ignoring all those seemingly
urgent emails from my bosses and
maybe to be missing a friend's birthday
party
but as soon as i get to a place of real
quiet
i realize that it's only by going there
that i'll have anything
fresh or creative or joyful to share
with my wife or bosses or friends
otherwise really i'm just foisting on
them my exhaustion or
my distractedness which is no blessing
at all
and so when i was 29 i decided to remake
my entire life
in the light of going nowhere one
evening i was coming back from the
office it was after midnight i was in a
taxi
driving through times square and i
suddenly realized that i was racing
around
so much i could never catch up with my
life
and my life then as it happened was
pretty much the one i might have dreamed
of as a little boy i had really
interesting friends and colleagues
i had a nice apartment on park avenue
and 20th street
i had to me a fascinating job writing
about world affairs
but i can never separate myself enough
from them
to hear myself think or really to
understand if i was truly happy
and so i abandoned my dream life
for a single room on the back streets of
kyoto japan
which was the place that had long
exerted a strong
really mysterious gravitational pull on
me
even as a child i would just look at a
painting of kyoto
and feel i recognized it i i knew it
before i ever laid eyes on it
but it's also as you all know a
beautiful city
encircled by hills filled with more than
2 000
temples and shrines where people have
been sitting still
for 800 years or more
and quite soon after i moved there i
ended up where i still am
with my wife formerly our kids in a
two-room apartment in the middle of
nowhere where
we have no bicycle no car no tv i can
understand
and i still have to support my loved
ones as a travel writer
and a journalist so clearly this is not
ideal for job advancement
or for cultural excitement or for social
diversion
but i realized that it gives me what i
prize
most which is days and hours
i have never once had to use a cell
phone there i
almost never have to look at the time
and every morning when i wake up really
the day stretches in front of me
like an open meadow and when life
throws up one of its nasty surprises as
it will more than once
when a doctor comes into my room wearing
a grave expression or
a car suddenly veers in front of mine on
the freeway
i know in my bones that it's the time
i've spent going nowhere
that is going to sustain me much more
than all the time i've spent racing
around to
bhutan or easter island
i'll always be a traveler my livelihood
depends on it
but one of the beauties of travel is
that it allows you to bring
stillness into the motion and the
commotion
of the world i once got on a plane
in frankfurt germany and a young german
woman came down and sat next to me and
engaged me in very
friendly conversation for about 30
minutes
and then she just turned around and sat
still
for 12 hours she didn't once turn on her
video monitor
she never pulled out a book she didn't
even go to sleep
she just sat still and something of her
clarity and calm
really imparted itself to me i've
noticed more and more people
taking conscious measures these days to
try to open up a space
inside their lives some people go to
black hole resorts
where they'll spend hundreds of dollars
a night in order to hand over their cell
phone and their laptop
to the front desk on arrival some people
i know
just before they go to sleep instead of
scrolling through their messages or
checking out youtube
just turn out the lights and listen to
some music
and notice that they sleep much better
and wake up
much refreshed i was once
fortunate enough to drive into the high
dark mountains behind los angeles where
the great poet and singer and
international heartthrob
leonard cohen was living and working for
many years
as a full-time monk in the mount baldy
zen center and i wasn't entirely
surprised when the record that he
released
at the age of 77 to which she gave
the deliberately unsexy title of old
ideas
went to number one in the charts and 17
nations in the world
hit the top five in nine others
something in us i think is crying out
for the sense of intimacy
and depth that we get from people like
that who take the time and trouble
to sit still and i think many of us have
the sensation i certainly do
that we're standing about two inches
away from a huge screen
and it's noisy and it's crowded and it's
changing with every second
and that screen is our lives and it's
only by stepping back and then further
back
and holding still that we can begin to
see what the canvas means
and to catch the larger picture and a
few people do that for us
by going nowhere
so in an age of acceleration nothing can
be more exhilarating
than going slow and in an age of
distraction
nothing is so luxurious as paying
attention
and in an age of constant movement
nothing
is so urgent as sitting still
so you can go on your next vacation to
paris or hawaii or new orleans
i bet you will have a wonderful time
but if you want to come back home alive
and full of fresh hope
in love with the world i think you might
want to try
considering going nowhere thank you
you